[Music]
now congress has been busy lately trying
to find enough money to extend the debt
ceiling pay for an infrastructure bill
and forgive student debt now many
americans think we can't do all that
because people don't pay their fair
share of taxes but i disagree in fact i
think we could solve all of america's
problems if the irs stopped
investigating the people we've been
chasing down to pay their taxes and let
them cheat don't know what i mean let me
explain in a segment called how did we
get here
[Music]
congress is struggling right now to pass
a much-needed infrastructure bill but
republicans are claiming that america
doesn't have trillions of dollars to
spend on frivolous stuff like
infrastructure child care and student
loan forgiveness but you know america be
lying
america is that friend who's balling in
the vip section of the club but when you
ask her about the 50 she owes you
america gets all loud and asks you why
you're bothering her about an old funky
little fifty dollars but instead of
bottle service america is buying
dick-shaped spaceships that don't even
go to space and instead of fifty dollars
you're wondering when you can get some
student debt relief well i'm gonna sit
here tonight and figure all of these
problems out because who knows more
about struggling to pay bills and being
in debt than someone who spent 15 years
doing improv
zip zap broke
yes and i'm overdrawn
can i get a suggestion oh i can't afford
one great
now last month the treasury department
released a study saying the tax gap the
difference between the taxes owed and
the amount collected is about 600
billion dollars a year or one pair
yeezys now that's a lot of money owed to
the us government and the irs is very
serious about finding the people who owe
it but they're not looking where you
think they are according to a report by
pro-publica the irs spends a
disproportionate amount of their time
and resources chasing down the people
who make the least money that's right
they go to the poorest counties and look
at people who claim the earned income
tax credit that's a tax credit that was
created to refund tax money to the
working poor in fact if you claim the
earned income tax credit you're more
likely to face irs scrutiny than someone
making 20 times as much which is crazy
that's like batman deciding to let the
joker go so he can focus on some guy
fishing without a license
so the irs uses a disproportionate
amount of resources to collect the
smallest number of tax dollars from the
poorest people but they aren't just
looking for poor people like a cop at a
speed trap they're also on the lookout
for people of color like a cop at a
speed trap
according to a recent investigation by
the route people who live in
disproportionately non-white counties
are audited at higher rates in fact the
irs seems to specifically audit places
where rich people aren't like rural
mississippi or any coffee shop that
doesn't have oat milk now here's a map
of where america audits at high rates
okay and here's the distribution of
non-white people in america
these two maps could look more similar
if they were named mary kate and ashley
so
is poor people cheating on their taxes
the reason the u.s government is broke
no but also if you think about it no
first of all the irs themselves have
said that when they catch people who
misused the earned income tax credit
those people usually cheated by mistake
because the law is so complicated which
is ridiculous paying taxes shouldn't be
more confusing than building an ikea
dresser because in this case when you
end up with three screws left over you
could go to jail
second of all the majority of the money
owed to the irs is owed by rich people
who simply refuse to pay their taxes now
i'm not talking about tax breaks and
loopholes i'm talking about the tax
equivalent of sitting down at a
restaurant ordering a stake and when the
bill comes saying pass
on top of that the top 10 percent of
income earners who cheat on their taxes
or refuse to pay will cost the u.s about
five trillion dollars over the next 10
years that's a terrillian with an r
that's right i prefer to go buy the
second letter
the rich owe the irs over 20 times more
than poor people do but the treasury
department says it's easier to audit
poor people they are literally
overlooking bank robbers to catch a
customer who accidentally took the
teller's pin so let's go back to where
we started i said i was going to find us
enough money to pay for infrastructure
child care and student debt well the
price tag for the original
infrastructure bill was estimated at 3.5
trillion dollars over 10 years and the
brookings institute said for giving 50
000 in student debt for every borrower
in the whole country would cost one
trillion dollars and the american
families plan that offers child care for
working families would cost an estimated
225 billion dollars now if you add that
up carry them one bag of gugu that's
about 4.7 trillion dollars which means
if we collect unpaid taxes from the
wealthiest 10 percent we can do
everything on that list and have about
300 billion dollars left over for
margaritas we did it guys
we figured out how to solve all of
america's problems i swear i must be
some kind of genius
either that or the irs congress and the
treasury department are overlooking
wealthy white people and systematically
burdening poor and non-white people with
an unequal share of america's fiscal and
financial responsibilities no
america couldn't possibly be that racist
i'm probably just a genius but at least
we know how we got here
[Applause]
[Music]
you